we're asked what are the domain and
range of the sine function
so to think about that let's actually
draw the sine function out and what i
have here on the left hand side right
over here i've got a unit circle and i
can let me
truncate this a little bit i don't need
that space right there so let me clear
that out so i have a unit circle on the
left hand side right over here and i'm
going to use that to figure out the
values of sine of theta for a given
theta so on the unit circle this is x
and this is
y
or you could even view this as the well
we could just use as x or y and so for
given theta we can see where that angle
entered the terminal side of the angle
intersects the unit circle and then
those the y coordinate of that point is
going to be sine of theta
and over here i'm going to graph
still y in the vertical axis
but i'm going to graph the graph of y is
equal to sine of theta y is equal to
sine of theta and on the horizontal axis
i'm not going to graph x but i'm going
to graph theta you can view theta as the
independent variable here it's going to
be theta is going to be in radians in
radians so we're essentially going to
pick a bunch of thetas and then come up
with what sine of theta is and then
graph it
so let's set up a little bit of a table
here let's set up a little bit of a
table and so
over here i have theta and over here
we're going to figure out
what sine of theta is and we could do a
bunch of theta values we could start
we could start let's say we start at
zero
let's say we start at theta is equal to
zero what is sine of theta going to be
well when the angle is zero we intersect
the unit circle right over there the y
coordinate of this is still zero this is
the point this is the point one comma
zero
the y coordinate is zero so sine of
theta is zero or we could say sine
of zero is equal to zero sine of zero is
equal to
zero now let's try theta is equal to
pi over two
theta is equal to pi over two i'm just
doing the ones that are really easy to
figure out so if theta is equal to pi
over two that's the same thing as a
ninety degree angle so the terminal side
is going to be
right along the y-axis just like that
and where it intersects where it
intersects
the
unit circle is right over here and what
point is that
well that's the point
zero comma one so what is sine
of pi over two
well sine of pi over two is just the y
coordinate right over here it is one
sine of pi over two is one let's keep
going and you might see a little pattern
here we're just going more and more
around the circle so let's think about
what's what
what happens when theta is equal to pi
when theta is equal to pi
what is sine of pi
well we intersect the unit circle right
over there that coordinate is negative 1
0
sine is the y-coordinate so this right
over here is sine of pi sine of pi is 0.
let's go to three pi over two
three pi over two
well now we've gone three quarters of
the way around
around the
circle we intersect the terminal side of
the angle intersects the unit circle
right over here and so based on that
what is sine of 3 pi over 2
well this point right over here is the
point negative let me be careful is 0
is 0
negative 1.
the sine of theta is the same thing as
the y coordinate of the y coordinate
sine of theta so theta when when theta
is pi over 2 sine of theta or when
theta's 3 pi over 2 sine of theta is
equal to
negative one
and let's come full circle let's come
full circle here
so let's go all the way to theta
equaling two pi let me do a color i'll
just use the yellow here what happens
when theta is equal to two pi well then
we've gone all the way around the circle
and we're back to where we started and
the y coordinate is zero so sine of 2 pi
is once again zero and if we were to
keep going around we're going to start
seeing as we keep incrementing the angle
we're going to start seeing the same
pattern emerge again well let's try to
graph this
so when theta is equal to zero sine of
theta is zero
when theta is equal to pi over two
when theta is equal to
pi over 2
pi over 2
sine of theta is 1. so we'll use the
same scale so sine of theta
sine of theta is
equal to 1. this is i'll make this this
is one on this axis and on that axis so
we can maybe see a little bit of a
parallel here
when theta is equal to pi
sine of theta is zero so when theta is
equal to pi
sine of theta is zero so we go back
right over there
when theta is equal to 3 pi over 2 so
that would be right over here
3 pi over 2
sine of theta is negative 1. so this is
negative 1 over here i'll do the same
scale over here i'll make this negative
i'll make let me make draw a little bit
i'll make this negative one
and so sine of theta is negative one
and then when
theta is two pi sine of theta is zero so
when theta is two pi
two pi
sine of theta is zero and so we can
connect the dots you can try other
points in between and you get something
you get a graph that looks something
like this it looks something like that's
my best attempt at drawing it freehand
it looks something
something like this there's a reason why
curves that look like this are called
sinusoids because they're the graph of a
sine function so
just like
just like this but that's not the entire
graph we could keep going we could go we
could add another pi over 2 if you added
another pi over 2. so if you go to 2 pi
and then you add another pi over 2 so
you could view this as 2 and a half pi
or however you want to think about it
then you're going to go back over here
so then you're going to get back to sine
of theta being equal to 1. so you're
going to go back to this point right
over here and you could keep going you
go another pi over 2 you're going to go
back to this point and you're going to
be over here and so the curve
the curve
or the function sine of theta is really
defined for any theta value
any real theta value that you choose so
any theta value you see well what about
negatives i mean obviously i agree as
you keep increasing theta like this we
just keep going around and around the
circle and this pattern kind of emerges
but what happens when we go in the
negative direction well let's try it out
what happens if we were to take
if we were to take negative pi over 2.
so let me do that
so negative pi over 2
well that's going right over here
and so we intersect the unit circle
right over there the the y coordinate is
negative 1. so sine of negative pi over
2 is negative 1. and we see that it just
continues
it just continues so sine of theta is
defined for any positive negative or any
theta a positive or negative
non-negative zero anything so it's
defined for anything
so let's go back to the question so i
could just keep drawing this function
on and on and on so let's go back to the
question
what is the domain
what is the domain
what is
the domain
of sine of the sine function and just as
a reminder the domain are all of the the
inputs over which the function is
defined or all of the valid inputs into
the function that the function will
actually spit out a valid answer so what
is the domain of the sine function
well we already saw we can put in any
theta here so you could say the domain
the domain is all
all real
numbers all real
all
real numbers
now what about the range
what
about
the
range well just as a review the range is
sometimes in more technical math classes
called the image it could it's the set
of all the values that the function can
actually take on well what is that set
what is the range here what's all the
values that y equals sine of theta could
actually take on well we see that it
keeps going between positive one
it keeps going between positive one and
then to negative one and then back to
positive 1 and then negative 1 it takes
on all the values in between so you see
that sine of theta
sine of theta is always going to be less
than or equal to 1 and it's always going
to be greater than or equal to negative
1. so you could say that the range of
sine of theta is the set of all numbers
between negative 1 and positive 1 and it
includes negative 1 and 1 and that's why
we put brackets here instead of
parentheses